the premise of our book influencing up
is that in today's complex fast changing
world to really be successful it's no
longer sufficient just to do your job
one has to take initiative in seizing
new opportunities see new possibilities
new audiences new customers and solving
problems before they really develop this
also demands that one be able to
influence certainly your boss but also
those further up the organization and
the question is how do you influence
those that you can't control central to
the notion of influence is a law of
reciprocity and the law of reciprocity
says that if I do something for you you
owe me what then we expect to get paid
back for things that we do for other
people the phrase and honest day's work
for an honest day's pay symbolizes that
sort of exchange so what you want to do
to influence people that you don't have
formal authority over is to figure out
what they need and we use the concept of
currencies and think of multiple
currencies what does the other person
need do they need information do they
need support do they need going to a
third party and getting their sort of
agreement do they need to make sure you
stay within budget well what are their
major needs and what it is that you need
it may be very different than what the
other person needs and to influence
other people you need to give other
people what they need in exchange for
what you need
if you want to build a relationship with
your boss its first of all important to
do things which are trustworthy and
often withholding information breaks
trust often we raise an issue in a very
circuitous or indirect way and that
makes the boss suspicious the other
thing is to really be on the boss's side
you have to understand the boss's world
and we tend to see the world through our
eyes and not take the time of trying to
understand how the world seems through
the boss's eyes the main takeaway of the
book is that you an employee can be much
more powerful than you think you can be
and secondly that to be more powerful is
not to take away the power of others but
to build your own power and you can
build your own power in a win-win
situation power is not a fixed amount so
the more you have unless I have in most
cases of power is a variable it's
possible for you boss to be highly
powerful and for me to be powerful and
what we have seen too often is not that
the boss takes away the junior partners
power but the junior partner takes away
his or her own power and we want to give
it back